تحدث جاريد كوشنر ، صهر الرئيس دونالد ترامب ،
باستفاضة عن
خطة الإدارة لحل
الصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني ، لكنه
كشف عن القليل من التفاصيل حول
ما يسمى بصفقة القرن التي تحدث عنها
كيرشنر مساء الخميس في
معهد واشنطن لـ  سياسة الشرق الأدنى
وفي خطاب مدته 45 دقيقة ،
كشف عن القليل من التفاصيل ، إن وجدت ، حول
محتويات الخطط التي قال إن هدفها
هو ترك الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين في وضع
أفضل ، واعترف بأنها واحدة من
أصعب المشاكل في العالم التي يجب حلها ،
لكنه قال إنه  متفائل بأنه إذا
توصل الجانبان إلى هذا بمنظور جديد
وأعطاه نظرة مفتوحة
دون الحكم مسبقًا على إمكانية تحقيق
أشياء أفضل في المستقبل لكلا
الجانبين ، فقد كان هذا قيد العمل الآن لمدة
عامين وحتى الآن لا يزال هناك عدد
قليل جدًا  الأشخاص الذين يبدو أنهم يعرفون
المحتوى الكامل للخطة التي قالت إدارة ترامب
في الماضي إن
خطتهم تحل جميع قضايا الوضع النهائي
وهي القدس بور  يتعامل مع
اللاجئين بالإضافة إلى الأمن ، لكن
الإدارة رفضت الالتزام
بحل الدولتين الذي يمثل
الإجماع الدولي على
الخيار الوحيد لحل
النزاع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني ، في حين
أن الخطة كلما تم إصدارها تواجه
صفقة صعبة ومسارًا أكثر صرامة.  على جانبي
الصراع الإسرائيلي الفلسطيني قطع الفلسطينيون
الاتصال بالبيت الأبيض بعد أن
اعترف ترامب بالقدس عاصمة
لإسرائيل والتزم بنقل
السفارة من مكانها في تل أبيب إلى
حيث هي الآن في القدس.
قالوا إنهم سيرفضون أي
خطة طرحتها إدارة ترامب ،
بينما فاز رئيس الوزراء
بنيامين نتنياهو للتو بولاية
خامسة في منصبه وهو في منتصف
مفاوضات الائتلاف لمحاولة
تشكيل حكومته اليمينية مع
بعض شركاء الائتلاف هؤلاء.  قالوا
إنهم سيرفضون كل ما يطرحه ترامب
إذا كان يتضمن أي
تنازلات للفلسطينيين  هل
يضغطون على نتنياهو من أجل ضم
الضفة الغربية بالكامل أو أجزاء منها ، مما يعني أن
هذا قد يكون
بيعًا صعبًا للغاية بالنسبة لكلا الجانبين ، أما بالنسبة للخطط التي
سيتم طرحها فسيأتي هذا في وقت ما بعد
أن ينهي نتنياهو مفاوضات الائتلاف ، لذلك من
الممكن تصور إطلاق  ما يسمى
بصفقة القرن يمكن أن يأتي في
غضون أسابيع قليلة
ولد ليبرمان سي إن إن القدس